babbo natale dice o lavori
oggi dovremmo stappare da babbo natale
ma nepi con i suoi aiutanti di puglia io
non so cosa sono i vuole prendersi e
trasformarci organi si può metterci la
quale vorrei farti a fettine come
altresì promessa ma la scoprire cosa
questo è scritto sembra fantastica
adatto per questo periodo ovviamente
continuerà anche dopo questi titoli
natalizie non sono un po
8 20 tiri comodi richiamo di questi
anche la
negazione l'albero di natale
lei pensa che dobbiamo andare di qua a
piedi ma che non mette volte si
straccerà vita ormai giulietta nostra
bravissimo proprio allora vediamo cosa
c'è da dire che carriera sei pronto a
fare il tour del negozio di santa
ragione babbo natale quindi questo è uno
degli elfi malefici che aiuta il babbo
natale e così qua per questo non era
parte del tour a ok qualcuno esiste non
sono stato io scrivete nei commenti qui
a te volte dispera celle rabita le
abbiamo già si sfracella brema nata
invece ma questo è quello che è successo
alla fabbrica di regali
regali
e tutta la va praticamente stato dovuto
forse alla fine incontreremo babbo
natale malefico non lo so si trasformerà
in qualche regalo ma se buon papà si
passò per melo
ti sei sono giornata
insomma della prima di allora bisogna
stare attenti perché viene trasformato
in un regalo e viene risucchiato da quei
tubi vedi questi così sparano regali mi
sono speso per loro per la seconda volta
come ho fatto io sono ancora qui ma è
già vivissima questo escape
ho capito siamo nel nastro trasportatore
dei regali ai bisogni andare al
contrario bisogna cercare di stadi noi
perché altrimenti stecca di vai poi
batte per i care inceneritore tipo
quindi volta in combinata che non emette
un
manufatto
porticina
morbidone quella porticina non la vedo
che non avevi
bassissimo i regali aiuto ragazzi non
hanno métropole l'inceneritore che sono
riuscito guarda quel folletto nardis e
brucia o no babbo natale più attivo sta
pure bruciando i folletti
ok sono sulla carta dativo è infatti
deve staccare cosa che bello ci sono il
record e vendono minuto e un altro è
quasi un altro le coppe sono i feed
spinner che pino attenta al mio
difficilissimo e poi sulle carte si
trova bene ma è bello vedere i
giocattoli giganti non micah micah ritmo
se babbo natale davvero impazzito presto
meta per scuola porta ecco la guarda c'è
scritto babbo natale dice o lavori a
fare o no
babbo natale sta lanciando dei dolciumi
sul pavimento dobbiamo evitarli è già
passato va anzi sarò bravissimo premio
che è vitale uno stretto rassegnando
tante volte questa volta ma voi avete
lasciato mi piace lo so che non mi piace
è lasciato mi piace entro quattro
secondi vi porterà fortuna per quello
che desiderate per
natale arriverà veniva sotto niente
giocare così 4 3
che cosa dice questo questo e questo
questo folletto dice che babbo natale ha
creato una specie di
dimensione caramella ha infatti queste
sono le caramelle vedi anche se sta male
bisogna saltare sopra sembrano tipo dei
verbi attentato un cadere sotto nel
zucchero filato di jelly beans sempre la
nota che sono bruciati marcarino questi
perché coloratissima e sono tutti
diversi di space
si sta divertendo
cercavano la favola per un'ora è la
parte per vitale torta al cioccolato e
cioccolando lissimo e poi ai biscotti al
cioccolato e venduto tantissimo mentre
torta al cioccolato
prendi me è bellissimo queste skyroom
ora qui ci sono dei lecca lecca invece
che belli
da qui ecco la porta della juve di
quelli una cascata di gioco wow oh che
bello venditore ii e iii ma affetto ma
abbiamo sbagliato strada non era poi
penso che dobbiamo saltare qualche dove
sei finito sono saltato giù a lato ma le
cose viste al tar e poi qua
allora credo di aver capito eco vitale
laggiù vediamo se si sfracella di nuovo
come faccio a sfruttare è caduto ne sono
rimasto sciolto nella fontana di
cioccolato
ecco questo perché tu volevi prendere la
scorciatoia andare nella fondamenti
cioccolate vice è risalito sopra ecco
vitale
tentare nel prossimo ciao sono sopra un
pacco regalo gigante avevo le volevo
proprio nel tuo gigante
io credo che sui pacchi regalo giganti
che bene
qualcuno ha già dato che cosa vorreste
per natale se volete scrivetecelo nei
commenti
noi cosa vogliamo per natal vitale di
sicura volendosi infinite di doversi
cibo soprattutto d'oggi perché tu per
goloso mobbing ero cartaceo chi no ma
perché è vero che
una schiappa
il folletto qui dice gli enti stanno
facendo dei regali giganti sali sui
regali ok vedere se sono prestiti sì
andiamo dove ci porterà davvero no non
mi dire che le foci mangerà primi pezzi
si no stiamo
questo milan è davvero gigante stiamo
del re carlo ho capito adesso sai che
bello
dove dobbiamo andare ma dobbiamo
attraversare tutto il regalo
quindi dentro questo pacco regalo
gigante sia vengono si pose all'amico
il trenino di legno poi altre cubi di
legno
quindi stiamo dicendo che cosa vogliamo
noi per natale evitare tantissimo cibo e
tu che cosa vuoi invece io vorrei
dei libri mi raccomando leggete leggete
le tante ma anche mangiare importante è
bellissimo leggera gialla anche on line
su un tappeto per bergonzi è ho capito
quindi a squadre
[Musica]
veloci
pro bisogna stare attenti e dove salti
come fai da te ne vai questo è facile
non è bene di fedelissimo quasi fatta
per quanto tempo rimarremo bloccati ho
un'idea devi fermarti e camminare
pianissimo poi presenti
tutto guardate che poi non mi piacciono
proprio orto è ci sono quasi non ci
credo già quasi fatta mi sono fatto
arrivando a priva di vita lei è
stato ti raggiungo adesso ecco vitale
della zucca e fratello vedevo stessi
sprezzante ma no il mio fratello
siamo io vi ho una tale gigante sta
mangiando e bevendo il latte e mangiando
i risi con totti quindi dobbiamo passare
di nascosto dalla porta misteriosà che
se li è come lui e quindi vi dico dov'è
e quindi latte e biscotti té cam bra no
no non c'è ma già mangiato come ti ha
mangiato devi andare a nella porta
l'impressione alla faccia cattiva
dell'altro scusa è abituato a mangiare
le persone è come pensiamo finiti lì
quindi vuol dire che usciremo da lì ma
da lì di babbo natale non saresti mai
aspettato dice dal quello di babbo
natale
scritto o no temo stati mangiati da
babbo natale gigante usciamo da qua
allora mangiato le patatine fritte anche
lei azione della pineta scozia o un
burger blu che era andato a male tra
l'altro
ovviamente tutti interi non masticano
nella spina dorsale
bisogna cosa stare sulla costola ok
bisogna saltare nelle cotto leo che cosa
sono queste ossa di babbo natale il
cuore attento ci sto provando non cadere
adesso ti lascio andare avanti così non
ci confondiamo ci sono tutti noi stiamo
già nella tua parte prenotò
sei pronto a parlare per evitare che ha
tra l'altro appeso anche le palline a
quella che chiede tra l'altro di natale
non penso
sull'ultimo sbattuto
ripetere ogni volta
ok con calma
guarda ci sono dei passaggi devi andare
quindi nei lati perché c'è un pò stanza
per fare aspetta aspetta forse
l'ultimo
vero ridare finalmente ce l'ha fatta
allora vediamo che mise il folletto dice
che se premiamo il pulsante viola
apparirà una slitta e voi nonostante
verde per andare a testa quello che
vorrei quanto alla svista cesarea e
quello invece è quella per farla partire
il set atleta si scivola smetta andiamo
nella stessa città dove di riguardo che
mettiamo st d'acqua
ottimo e adesso chi lo preme il bottone
il bottone a questo via
ocalan se volevate che già finita
dell'igloo andiamo nel gruppo primo è
fighissimo il rumor stato di stage
bellizzi mattisi sfracellata che lui
fatto naturale niente siamo nel
nell'isola refrigerata e continuiamo ad
andare infatti chi c'è un nel
fondo per impararlo non credo a cadere
nel ghiaccio diventerai come questo è il
boom no no no no
vediamo proprio a cadere io sono più
forti di te per il momento si è fatta
wav e bellissimo anche qua tema il polo
nord immagine è beh sì un fatica mi ha
superato dovrà fare il pesato anche a un
verme bere beve troppo va l'ultima volta
siamo adesso dobbiamo restare a casa e
su queste cubetti di ghiaccio gigante
era
presentata all italia non devo fare
tutta la canoa ecco ei e ora è che
questa può farmi devo buttare
o no ti devi buttare evitando la parte
blu come hai fatto sono sopreso lato a
quello dopo ecco se scendi piano piano
riesce bloccati sulla roccia guarda così
è un po difficile puoi saltare dopo che
guardiamo dall'alto anni no sono
riusciti a superare il primo che ho
fatto non lo so neanche io perché poi
sarebbe morta dove possiamo farcela
dobbiamo arrivare laggiù a quella
cittadina tranne ok ho scoperto cosa c'è
che non va iper che moriamo sempre
perché se rimani fermo vieni ghiacciato
versiamo giorni che muore quindi non si
può camminare non si può rimanere fermi
bisogna saltare in continuazione certo è
difficilissimo perché è vero ma io
ce l'ho fatta non ci credi sognava ma
rubiconi passetti bravissimo a saltare
andare piano piano più avanti da evitare
quei parte
l'abbiamo pagata mantenuta barra di mila
volte e ora dove finiremo per un per la
città di natale perché carino avevano
finito gioco dai cieli blu che già
spetta sbrigativo piccoli
mario re le gru dove stiamo babbo natale
guardano wow c'è un albero di natale
gigante sempre più bella perché gruppo
si è iscritti presto arrampicati
all'albero di natale work è una delle
scale quest'albero fini al posto di rame
avere
il pallino di natale sono luminose è
infatti
diventa sempre più difficile perché sono
sempre più va bene ma dopo ben tredici
nei rami e c'è anche ma che behrami
finiscono in un certo punto bisogna
camminare sulle luci sulle voci sul cavo
delle luci si va bene
eccolo lo vedi ti devo stare super
attento altrimenti dovrò rifare tutto
daccapo
e poi gli altri rami che figo però i
tuoi dentro all'albero di natale
ma questi ce n'è ancora tantissimi mondo
siamo in alto wow ci sono quasi ok come
si fa no non mi dica che sei caduto sono
sono caduto fuori su un ramo
l'uomo
che cosa vuol dire che forse non è
quella la strada o no
stiamo in trappola bisogna cercare di
salire la sopra o forse saltando e non
mi fatta lira perché
e così abbiamo sotto ma chi sei perché
era buggata quel livello
quindi non funzionava purtroppo però
ecco cinque stati sulla montagna ci
siamo quasi devo assolutamente prendere
il badge sapete che colleziono i badge
quali si è votato in alto a oh che bello
quando si perde ogni caso è aspetta
adesso non cadevo ascoltare qui
sei caduta diede molto in alto no c'ero
quasi riuscito
sono invece la montagna ok ci sono cose
ce l'ho fatta da evitare quindi parte ma
anche ok arrivo eco vitale dai facciamo
allora piano piano è trovata
1 corso fatto grave ritardo
di laser ma sono grandissime ok sono
molto più grandi del normale
questi sono laser di never non lo so
ok ce l'ho fatta non so neanche io come
con gli alberi in cui erano un uomo che
quelle città la città di natale wow che
bello gli avvocati dovremo affrontare
babbo natale cattivo ti daranno il
meglio in vediamo cosa farò
totale non rimarrà a pazzo per sempre
preso e che
cosa mi piace sono qua quattro case lire
su cui cliccare per vedere i nostri
altri video mercato su quella che
preferite
oriali gara